Marvel just announced
that Iron Man will now be
a 15-year-old black girl
named Riri Williams.
-FUNCHES: Hell, yeah. -And
the-the Internet... Yes. I know.
Very awesome.
The Internet, of course,
responded in it usual calm
and open-minded manner.
"Iron man is woman? Really?!
(Bleep) you, Marvel,
you getting sucks!"
(laughter)
-(applause)
It's true. -Well...
-Yup.
-BRAUNGER: Hey, I got...
-The math checks out on that.
-BRAUNGER: I got
to tell you--
I love getting sucks.
Thanks. Thanks, everybody.
HARDWICK:
Comedians, uh,
seeing these guys angry
can be a lot of fun.
So, what's a plot line
from the new Iron Man
that'll piss them off?
-Ron.
-Okay.
Iron Man fires all the Avengers
and replaces them
with the cast
of RuPaul's Drag Race.
-(cheers and applause)
-HARDWICK: That'd be amazing.
-That'd be amazing.
-BRAUNGER: It was good.
FUNCHES:
It's pretty good.
Marcella.
She get's into
a polyamorous relationship
with the female Ghostbusters.
HARDWICK:
All right, yeah. Points.
-(applause and cheering)
-Matt Braunger.
The villain's name is literally
Comic Book-Collecting
Mediocre White Guy
Who Lives With His Mom.
-HARDWICK: All right, perfect.
Perfect. -ARGUELLO: Ooh. Wow.